Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij Questo
è il secondo episodio di Outlast ragazzi
Vi lascio al video Purtroppo però
ragazzi il primo episodio ho visto che
l'hanno messo vietato ai 18 ci sta
perché Outlast Purtroppo è quello che è
quindi Eh forse succederà anche a questo
video quindi mi dispiace che è limitata
come visibilità come serie però eh vabbè
che ci dobbiamo fare Comunque ragazzi
Buona visione e lasciate un bel like
Adesso Vabbè torniamo moribondi ma
torniamo vincitore che è importante Eh
io ho visto in totale che ci sono cinque
sfide così ragazzi Quindi questa era la
prima pensavo fosse molto tranquille
riusciremo in questo test prevediamo dai
Secondo te visto che questa è la seconda
la prima secondo me no Però vabbè Eh
ragazzi
mamma e mi fido eh maturità Ecco
torniamo nella parte horror della mia
vita grazie Dominick
Ah tritura le mele marce Va bene ok
altro ragazzi Io ho una certa paura dei
pagliacci quindi di me stesso capito
Sì effettivamente non sono simpatici
quelli negli horror specialmente
soprattutto adesso Combattiamo contro la
tipa con la marionetta Però vedi che è
sexy eh cioè l'ho visto ho visto un
video iniziale così una volta era sul
sito strano Non voglio sapere che Su che
sito statico
ora ragazzi non so se vi ricordate tu no
il film che si chiamava Hostel Beh
ascolta non è che c'ho 15 anni va bene
tutto era un film che aveva avuto un
sacco di successo perché appunto era un
sacco splatter e un po' il film che più
si avvicina Secondo me a quello che
potrebbe essere Outlast in realtà
Austria ragazzi non Guardate così
davvero Effettivamente sì allora io
posso spottare i nemici ok Il tasto r ti
fa vedere attraverso le pareti Vabbè qua
vedo che parte bene futherland la legna
dove si fotte Vabbè qua si può entrare
Ah scusa devo passare sotto è vero
Tranquilla tranquilla vai
tienes la puertas
gracias Buongiorno dovremmo fare un po'
di Outlast in napoletano autostina
napoletano
amici di Napoli ci potete aiutare nei
commenti Io sto solo a cucchiaiate Però
dall'altra parte
con giacca e maionese vediamo se riesco
a sporcare i nemici va lo uso sto coso
che tanti si ricarica Allora vediamo che
schiaccia sta roba giochiamo seri Ah
ecco eh non lo sto usando in questo
momento Ok allora io con Ok allora non
ci sono nemici ce n'è uno accovacciato
Ok ok Quindi questo è allora la si sta
facendo la cacca l'artefatto è tipo coso
per vedere di notte solo che vedi
attraverso figo e ce n'è uno là c'è un
tipo qua qua
una porta eh Spoon tutto perfetto
Oh cosa fa Cosa fa Cosa fa Oddio Secondo
me esplode Esplora Vediamo Ah ah ah
Sarei curioso di vedere come esplodere
Io sto aprendo tutte le porte in caso lo
apriamo Allora qua guardiamoci in giro
perché tanto non ha senso tanto Ahia
[__]
Favij in pericolo di vita Eh perché il
pericolo in vista perché il pericolo in
vista perché si è piantato un paletto
purtroppo non non sono attento alle cose
che faccio bello grazie Sì sì sì No
soprattutto Guarda questo qua come è
messo bene Ah guarda qui però guarda qua
Guarda guarda mi vedi Sì certo Guarda
cosa fai ma bravissimo va beh Ah lancio
i cuori No vabbè vabbè Non ci credo
schitto True Hearts No vabbè è
bellissimo tieni te lo lancio anche io
Ti lancio un cuore perché ti voglio bene
grazie Sono la posizione di cuori per
fare punti non so se facciamo Fammelo
dire un attimo lì Lancia corri per
vincere un biglietto Bravo vediamo
Ok manca uno Ecco eccolo fatto sì
dai se si è aperta la porta cosa abbiamo
vinto abbiamo vinto che c'è un nemico a
destra dobbiamo correre Arrivederci
Bravo aspetta gli tiro il cuore a
stronzo eh
Ma [__] Ok avanti Resisti allo
skimmer
devi correre corri finché non ti passa
Cioè
basta Porca [__] è bruttissimo lo
skinnerne ragazzi Ecco ho preso prendi i
biglietti Ecco li ho presi Ok Inserisci
il biglietto a Vinci gioco del canestro
gioco quello lì del del canestro ma io
gli posso dire una bottiglia Allora tira
il pallone alla bottiglia al pallone Sì
si trova ah C'è un tizio Ahia Porca
[__] che male sembra il caso
[__] Che dolore ma possibile Secondo
noi dobbiamo prendere i cuori tirali i
palloni Certo
Quello allora [__]
No lascia una Mira di merda ragazzi
terribile l'ho preso l'ho fatto ho fatto
ho fatto secondo biglietto ne manca uno
Vinci gioco delle palle nel secchio Non
voglio sapere che gioco è mmm non lo
voglio sapere palle nel secchio vediamo
allora Scusi lei sa cos'è palle nel
secchio Guarda che c'è un tizio che ci
guarda terribile Guarda Oddio
Arrivederci
ho chiuso la porta teoricamente non mi
dovrebbe vedere poi non lo so Oh tipo
a me Io sono a posto
due ore per fare questa cosa ma voi
[__] Abbastanza bene dai sì sì sì
sì Comunque dai non è andata così male
servono tu puoi curare adesso sì vieni
vieni Vai vai chiediamoci una curata
così intanto ti si ricarica prova prova
dove sei Ecco qua
allora un botto
cura Due tacche ottimo Ah dobbiamo
salire su Paperino e ora credo No non è
vero non vedo dobbiamo seguire e basta
spingi la barca
eh Capito Cioè Chiedo la trama sia
quella di farti rivivere i momenti della
tua vita in maniera migliore
Ah devo Dobbiamo staccare questo se vi
capita la barriera e l'ho trovata L'ho
trovata già disarma
Ah guarda qui ho fatto è riservato
teoricamente Sì io mentre spigo sta roba
c'è un manichino che assassino dura un
cadavere Cioè non è il massimo Dal
dentista Eh effettivamente l'anestesia
ci poteva stare qua non l'hanno fatto
questo Outlast è veramente Ahia
[__]
ma [__] tu sorella che male eh Io
vorrei stare è mikeshowsha sempre quello
occhio eh eh
Chi sei dei due
chi devo picchiare qua
non capisco chi sei dei due è fortnite
ok siamo di sopra comunque andiamo
avanti ragazzi
Esatto Uno l'ho fatto madonna questo
gioco È difficile sono troppe cose in
troppo poco tempo non si capisce nulla
raga' spingi per castigare In che senso
ok Oh c'è un mattone Bravo il mattone
che è sempre utile ma se io tiro sta
cosa qua al Paperino ma esplode Se piove
Sta qui Se stai messo male con la vita
non sto messo male per adesso ho anche
un kit un parroco Io sì quindi
Oh merda c'è un tipo che mi segue e tu
Vuoi spingere il coso io mi faccio
seguire sì vai vai sta arrivando
lo zio mi segue yeah mattoni in bocca
Madonna che botta gli ho dato ragazzi è
svenuto praticamente Vabbè Mamma mia
questi c'hanno delle
trivelle al posto delle mani è pazzesca
sta roba Io mi sto facendo dei giri che
non hai idea per tenertelo lontano acqua
insufficiente per galleggiare Orco và
dobbiamo trovare le valvole adesso ok
Sono sotto stavano Ah ecco l'ho trovato
una pazzesca e che culo
e adesso
i tubi per trovare la spinta giusta Va
bene allora aspetta e vengo di qua devo
Dobbiamo attivare tu L'hai trovata
l'altra no Brescia Ok io devo seguire il
tubo e metterli la pressione qua di qua
Sì Sì Sì Sì sto venendo e io ho trovato
l'altra mi sa Oh merda con Tizio
Che brutto
Eh ragazzi terribile Madonna San Giorgio
non puoi fare veramente un metro succede
di tutto ok una siringa che serve io
c'ho pure il tizio che mi segue quello
che quando sei pazzo eh ci sarà quella
giù forse l'ho trovata io eh
Ok io mi sa che una l'ho trovata
Ah c'è la tipa c'è quella pazza Oddio no
si è chiusa la porta che ho appena
aperto incredibile il dolore niente Sono
morto finisce ho trovato l'ho trovato
ce l'hai fatta là sopra c'è mi ha
buttato giù dalle scale c'è tutto sta
facendo Mi ha disintegrato la faccia
dove sta qua qua
mi hai preso alla fine ero morto Ok
perfetto
vediamo
a uno e qua non c'è bisogno di raggi x
Porca [__] via via via tanto Infatti io
ti difendono
Ok
veramente Non puoi curar Porca [__] C'è
un tizio via via via via via via usciamo
usciamo usciamo usciamo usciamo usciamo
dobbiamo tornare ai bambini Io comunque
vi dico una siringa Non lo so puoi
trainare anche me se salgo sopra sto
punto No Ah Eccole Eccolo Chi è Io
Abbiamo visto No devi triturare le mele
Adesso si sono alzati perché sono mele
marce capito adesso non voglio adesso
fanno finta di niente No non sono stato
io oggi vai Oddio devi triturare adesso
è come l'altro uno deve distrarre e
l'altro spingere capito vai Io spingo
Ah ok Sto spingendo Scusa
sei morto
quanto tempo
Minchia raga È incredibile È un'ora che
sta attaccata sta cosa vai vai vai vai
scappa due Eh son morti ce l'ho fatta
Ok
che Che razza di di imprecazione è vacca
pigra Vabbè me la segno va bene eh è
fatta ragazzi se riesco a ricaricarmi
Almeno vedo che dove sto andando non è
male io ok bene dobbiamo uscire a
ritornare ce la fai Eh sì dobbiamo
tornare alla navetta ci vediamo là No
m'ha preso all'ultimo non ci credo No
non ci posso credere
No vabbè ti salvo con la siringa Allora
non andare troppo Ecco come hai fatto ad
arrivare qua che è successo dopo allora
non ti preoccupare Guarda se se Miressi
subito ma non ho capito dove dobbiamo
andare andiamo a Terni ah ah Ma che
cazzo ma ti pare
dove dobbiamo uscire Come si esce da
questo posto di merda ma si passa di qua
Sì qui guarda
Ah è vero Eccoci Oddio
Ragazzi sto sudando no pazzesco ragazzi
incredibile ma veramente ma si può fare
sta vita allora sì Sì eccoci Eccoci
crede ce la tipa dove sei
Ha trovato la porta Io sono qua Eh non
so dove sto sfondando tutto per arrivare
adesso
Ecco quell'altra volta
porca vacca più sfigato del mondo se me
casca quello che sapete voi sapete pure
il nome rimbalzo
Però comunque hai nitrato la signora ho
visto cosa ha dentro a proposito di
completare la signora e hai tutta la mia
simpatia per averlo fatto Dove cacchio
si esce Ah eccoci qua io ti posso
rianimare Ah c'ha la signora signora Io
non so correre Abbia pietà posso solo
saltare Mike vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai scappa scappa
dopo Mettiti in salvo No non posso
lamentati dietro come nei peggiori film
Oh però completato l'ho completato anche
io sì perché credo che basti una persona
a completarlo forse ti dà un voto più
basso
neanche quando è morto gandal attenzione
che è ancora spoiler quello
cent'anni mi dice lucidità Max Se guardo
te secondo me dopo quello che abbiamo
giocato non è proprio al Max Eh però io
c'ho bisogno di tipo 10 10 anni nella
stanza quella là quindi di Goku super
star tranquilli perché in sanità mentale
sto gioco quindi ragazzi Questo era il
secondo episodio con Mike dovrei parlare
un po' più a bassa voce perché sono le
3:16 non so se ho visto ma chissenefrega
volevo ringraziarvi di cuore Mike ehm
perverso portato questa purga perché
comunque non è proprio una passeggiata a
Gardaland e ringrazio ovviamente anche
voi per aver visto il video lasciate un
bel mi piace ragazzi iscrivetevi al
canale passate anche da voi mikeshowsha
e noi come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video bella ragazzi